on va changer de sujet avec vous faut
sur lucas bonsoir on va parler de tous à
cheval
en tout cas on va parler de la fête du
cheval qui a lieu dimanche 23 septembre
alors dites-nous déjà dans combien de
clubs de france a lieu cette fête et
combien de clubs des iv on va voir
l'importance dans le département alors
vous avez raison de dire tous à cheval
qu'il ya une enquête de la sofres qui
met en exergue que 14 millions de
français souhaite monter à cheval et
environ 2000 iran français qui monte à
cheval de façon hebdomadaire 12 millions
il ya différents problèmes il faut avoir
des implantations hors d'un des
problèmes d'implantation foncière parce
que vous avez une recrudescence des
zones
vers l'urbanisation oui et puis il ya
aussi le facteur coût puisque les
collectivités locales et l'état
intervient pour ainsi dire pas avoir à
la marge seulement il ya des cas
particuliers comme le conseil général
des yvelines qui lui au contraire a bien
pris en compte ce désir de la population
et puis également l'économie que je les
leur club qu'ils sont privés les haras
nationaux les haras nationaux
alors il ya en fait 90% des clubs sont
des clubs privés
ouais le rallye reste plus qu'à en
national le rat des bréviaires qui est
justement dans département des yvelines
et dont la vocation initiale était
justement la reproduction
mais le privé ayant pris le pas sur
l'état le rôle de l'état n'est pas de
concurrencer l'activité privée s'est au
contraire de la promouvoir et puis après
de la laisser vivre de ses propres ailes
alors en tout cas pour cette fête du
cheval qu'elle dimanche 23 alors
peut-être 12 millions de français qui
n'osent pas qu'ils n'hésitent à faire du
cheval vont peut-être venir
combien de clubs participent dans les
yvelines alors en france vous avez
environ 10000 qu'une 10000 centre
équestre en ile de france vous en avez
800 et il y en a près de 200 dans les
yvelines
donc gros sous sont ouverts en fait
cette journée du cheval
il suffit de taper www.fff.fr le code
postal de votre ville et de langue ou de
l'endroit où voudriez aller en famille
avec les grands parents à poney ou à
cheval
les clubs sont ouverts pour accueillir
l'ensemble de la population française
alors parmi les clubs qui participent
notamment le poney l'ombre qui de la
celle saint cloud qui a été fondée par
jacinthe giscard d'estaing et qui est
une aussi des initiatrices de cette fête
du cheval tout à fait d'ailleurs elle a
eu par le passé la responsabilité de la
présidence de de 7,7 du châle juste
branche à 110 garder ça on l'a rencontré
dans open landes de la celle-saint-cloud
elle nous explique l'importance du
cheval en france
c'est à l'origine la fédération
française d'équitation et tous les clubs
hippiques de france qui ouvrent leurs
portes pour que les gens qui n'ont pas
encore eu l'occasion de découvrir ce
sport puisse venir qu'on leur explique
comment ça marche
qu'ils puissent approcher les poneys et
les chevaux et se sentent et se sentir
accueillis dans tous les clubs qui ce
jour là qui font des animations des
coudes et et des tas d'activités pour
montrer la diversité de ce sport
fédération française d'équitation et la
troisième fédération olympique sportives
en france avec plus de 700 mille
licenciés ce qui est colossal
ces quatre mille club donc tout le monde
à un club pas très loin de chez soi et
faut pas avoir peur d'y aller les
yvelines c'est un traditionnellement un
très grand département d'équitation
c'est un des plus importants des plus
anciens et il ya toutes les formes
d'équitation la foulée poney club pour
apprendre les écuries de compétition les
écuries bout on peut faire de la
promenade du western enfin toutes les
formes de pratiques possibles et
imaginables dans toutes les formes de
pratiques possibles et inimaginables
entendu un jet 110 jusqu'à un destin qui
n'est effectivement c'est la troisième
fédération olympique de france derrière
le tennis et le football a été de très
modestes pour le chiffre et des quatre
villes dont ses 10000 de ce que ya ceux
qui sont licenciés à la fédération
cette ville et puis les autres qui
d'autres clubs qui ne sont pas
l'essentiel
la fédération mais qui ont une activité
effective aux joueurs on dira que ce
qu'elle a dit sur la fin c'est à dire on
peut faire de multiples disciplines avec
le cheval ainsi pas simplement la balade
il ya aussi beaucoup de choses il ya eu
enfin discipline mais aussi le fait dire
que le cheval et aux sports ce que la
fête à la cuisine bio on peut on peut
utiliser a fait par exemple utiliser le
cheval 7 nov
d'ailleurs peut-être plus et puis c'est
un outil pédagogique qui qui permet à
des jeunes de prendre le biais des
adultes même de prendre deux soeurs dans
le sens de la responsabilité l'esprit de
décision
vous avez des enfants un peu introverti
qui justement retrouve en là dans la
pratique du poney un moyen
d'épanouissement et il n'y a pas plus
chez les enfants que chez les adultes la
discipline parce que là on voit des
images la voltige saut d'obstacles et
aussi d'autres choses peut faire du polo
de faire la promenade peut faire la
chasse à courre du bruit pic du saut
d'obstacles du groupe i du groupe au
complet de la randonnée
c'était le polygame le western de ce
côté là nous sommes pourvus le magasin
est bien achalandé et diversifiée dans
ses produits diversifiés et bien
achalandé aussi en adhérant via nombre
d'adhérents n'arrête pas de progresser +
58 % depuis 2002 puis tout à fait oui
c'est la fédération qu'elle vous fait
une fête du cheval encore cette perdront
populaire pourquoi vous faites une fête
du cheval puisque finalement c'est très
populaire l'équitation
oui mais c'est pour le faire connaître
encore un peu plus du grand public
oui vous êtes attirés peut-être des
nouveaux adhérents des nouvelles
personnes qui n'osent pas franchir le
pas tout à fait parce qu'il ya de
certaines intimidation pour entrer dans
un club d'abord le cheval en lui-même
était un
un d'animal impressionnant il fait 4 à
500 kg donc ça nécessite quand même un
effort personnel pour pouvoir pour
l'approcher mais le poney justement pour
ça tout à fait adapté pour les pour les
jeunes enfants
si vous avez quand même la moyenne d'âge
14 ans et on peut commencer à monter à
poney à partir de 2 ans et demi puis
c'était le club hippique c'est un lieu
de vie donc vous venez avec les parents
les grands parents voire les arrières et
donc il ya tout tout une ambiance qui
suivaient pas uniquement de monter sur
le poney mais également on apprend à
pêcher s'en occuper ce qui donne une
culture de la connaissance de l'animal
et du milieu rural et puis après
l'écologie bien bien pensé trop bien sûr
les bienfaits de l'éducation vous dites
c'est utile pour les enfants des enfants
un peu introverti
expliquez-nous comment un enfant
introverti le fait qu'ils montent sur un
poney par exemple ça peut lui donner
plus d'attrait il est obligé de prendre
des décisions
il suffit pas d'appeler papa maman pour
ce qu'on n'est pas tout seul voilà donc
il faut se décider et agir
oui mais c'était valable pour les
habitudes ont complètement changé leur
comportement même d'aider pdg de
l'entreprise privée le fait de match ça
m'a permis de m'apprendre à maîtriser
physiquement de de mieux le dominer de
de gérer une réunion etc
je reviens sur la mission du haras
national puisque finalement vous m'avez
dit un seul art à quito prévient dans
les yvelines
cocorico pour le département quel cette
mission propre
il ya un rat en fait de par région mais
à l'heure actuelle une réforme profonde
des rats pour justement réduire leur
mission à l'utile parce que c'est la
célébration ce sont des fonctionnaires
il ya une
je pense bien expliqué il ya des
problèmes économiques et puis il faut se
mettre dix jours se moderniser donc le
rôle des races décidé de coordonner les
différentes actions du secteur privé
et puis également le héron leurs
missions régaliennes en termes
d'administration de de l'élevage et de
est de la gestion du cheval en général
sur le plan sanitaire entre autres je
voudrais aussi revenir sur l'utilisation
du cheval dans la société moderne
aujourd'hui il sert plus à l'agriculture
et ne sert plus aux transports en règle
en règle générale malgré tout il ya
quand même encore des races de chevaux
qui sont utilisés comme les percherons
ça c'est important aussi de continuer
cette lignée de chevaux qui finalement
le percheron maintenant il n'a plus
d'existence utile j'ai envie de dire
alors c'est la france a cette
particularité d'avoir neuf races de
chevaux de trait alors et c'est le seul
pays d'europe qui a sauvegardé sera-ce
je vais dire quelque chose qui va
affoler les téléspectateurs c'est en
fait de circuit commercial de la
boucherie chevaline qui a sauvé c'est
parce que s'il ya pas de créneau et que
devait fermer mais supprimer ces
créneaux et que de big ça veut dire
qu'on supprime race parce que bon il
existe des débouchés qui sont un peu
marginaux et le débardage des
du bois dans les forêts vous avez le
travail des chevaux dans les vignes et
puis également ceux qui disent se
développe c'est le travail du cheval
dans les villes aussi pour tirer les
balayeuses ramasser les verts et cetera
ou dans les parcs et jardins la ville de
paris par exemple plusieurs chevaux pour
ramasser les entre autres les feuilles
et les menus travaux de départ toujours
vous avez l'acide pour des raisons de
sécurité aussi dans la police et la
gendarmerie et la garde républicaine le
chevalet est un élément d'approchant
plus de la population c'est moins
répressif que d'avoir un policier à
cheval à pied s'il est à cheval c'est
rassurant va vers le cheval c'est arras
un moyen de communication puis à cheval
vous voyez beaucoup plus pour surveiller
les parkings c'est utile alors justement
quelle utilisation du cheval dans la
société moderne
en tout cas la question que nous sommes
allés poser dans les rues de saint
quentin on écoute les réponses bonne
question comment on pouvait j'aurais pu
vous répondre
comment on peut l'utiliser certainement
aux thérapies pour certains enfants
cultivent et transporté en ville de nos
jours j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
policiers qui saint servais dans barry
parce que je crois que c'est plus facile
pour eux quand ils volent actuellement
poursuivre quelqu'un j'ai appris que
dans un village il ya un cheval crise et
du ramassage scolaire en france sait pas
où il va lui servir à lyon un jour mais
c'est sinon je sais pas à quoi ça vous
avez encore certaines villes ou
on prend le cheval pour les ordures
ménagères des choses comme ça c'est un
peu écologique quoi à part le loisir ben
malheureusement plus à grand chose qui
serait fut un temps on va dire avant les
chevaux vapeur mais non j'ai pas d'idée
barré à réapprendre aux gens marcher je
pas par rapport à la motricité tous à
développer la motricité
quoi d'autre base déplacer dans la
gendarmerie je pense notamment
et sinon j'ai vu à la télé qu'il y avait
quelques personnes qui pour labourer
leurs champs il reprenait ses techniques
ses techniques là et voilà mais voilà
enfin ils sont bien renseignés
alors il ya des personnes qu'on parlait
de thérapie et c'est important le cheval
peut servir à la thérapie il y avait
vraiment des enfants autistes qui j'ai
fait mes premières expériences 1968 et
où effectivement ça vos premières
expériences messieurs avec des enfants
qui étaient vraiment me souviens d'un
jeune il avait 7 ans il parlait pas du
tout non la rive bien monter à poney 2
fois par semaine
c'était dans un centre de regroupement
d'enfants
enfin handicapé par pour des raisons
essentiellement familial et le premier
mots qu'il a prononcés c'est le bo de
son poney et après tout s'est déclenché
tout d'un coup c'est comme un bouchon de
réseauter mais pourquoi alors le cheval
est un fluide g sont les émoussé il ya
un contact direct de deux corps de deux
êtres vivants si vous voulez ray alors
c'est sa vie c'est parti ça fait partie
du mystère et du mystère au combien
positif de la pratique de l'équitation
pas parce que sur 500 1000 personnes par
mois qu'ils souffrent d'un handicap
physique ou de troubles mentaux il y en
a cent mille qui pratiquent l'équitation
en loisir ou en thérapie donc c'est très
important et on fait même monter des
tétraplégiques à cheval et il son
ressort c'est ça qui était froide nerfs
de l'équitation c'est ça vous rend
heureux
le paradis est sur le dos des shows
c'est un proverbe arabe ça
la tragédie prover mentale et
l'application également pourvoyeur
d'emplois quarante cinq mille ans pour
tout à fait écouter l'économie en
ile-de-france et le demi du cheval en
flux directs indirects et induits ca
milliards 500 millions d'euros c'est des
mille emplois ouais parce que le cheval
il faut non seulement monter dessus mais
aussi il faut le soigner l enfant le le
c'est sûr que le mercredi le samedi et
dimanche vous avez un afflux de
participation mais les autres jours il
ya quelquefois moins de moins de monde
donc il faut en plus sortir il faut tout
à fait tout à fait comment on à en
augmenter le nombre de licenciés bien
fatalement il faut augmenter également
le nombre de clubs et et le nombre
d'employés alors une dernière question
pour clore cet entretien par dont le
prix souvent on dit ça coûte cher de
faire du cheval c'est est ce qu'il
redoute avant que vous disiez oui les
gens font un peu peur ce que le chevalet
et au et grands est peut-être le prix
aussi mais alors le prix il est clair
que si les collectivités locales joué le
jeu sous forme de chèques sport si vous
voulez hein parce que le tennis est
souvent bon marché parce que c'est ils
sont pris en charge tant au niveau du
fonctionnement que l'investissement par
les collectifs de galles c'est le cas du
football
les 103 y casser c'est vrai du tout
cette différence alors si vous voulez
savary si vous êtes dans un milieu rural
vous a fait mander prix de revient qui
sont moindres donc vous pouvez monter à
cheval pour moins cher que en cité ou si
le plus l'entreprise à louer un terrain
il est qu'il a fait taire en ville pour
plus cher à louis que les faut compter
combien de temps à partir de 15 euros
sous les 15 euros jusqu'à 30 euros mais
tout dépend tout dépend du produit 6 mai
15 euros par quoi par jour parce la
relancer non c'est qu'à 16 euros pour
une heure
ça peut rebuter
ben oui c'est sûr belle et les chevaux
faut les acheter pour les entretenir
leur donne à manger
c'est un vrai problème et je vous en
prie sur le plateau u7 8 et donc je vous
rappelle cette fête du cheval qui a lieu
dimanche 23 7 en voulaient à certains
bruits www.fff.fr
oui journée du 23 septembre
non c'est bon c'est alors inventé merci
beaucoup d'être venu trop tôt comparé
cette journée on va maintenant par les
mobilités une semaine de la mobilité
proposé à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'occasion pour nous de nous pencher sur
ce qu'ils laissent leur voiture au
garage ils ont bien raison pour aller
travailler
autrement eh bien nous avons suivi
michel bérenger qui lui pour aller
travailler utilisent un moyen fort
écologique et économique la marche à
pied on vous l'a dit et répété pour se
maintenir en forme il est recommandé de
pratiquer la marche au moins une demi
heure par jour
l'échelle bérenger calista entre amis le
broken elle est largement dans les clous
ils ne se déplacent pratiquement qu'à
pied pour se rendre sur son lieu de
travail pour aller manger le midi ce qui
représente environ une heure chaque jour
alors pourquoi ce choix la première
chose c'est que je ne conduis pas j'ai
pas de permis donc pas question je
pourrais très bien fait raccompagner en
voiture ce qui m'arrive de temps en
temps comme mon domicile est
relativement proche du demandeur de
travail de mon magasin
selon cet inimitable même s'il avait son
terme il continuerait de pratiquer cette
activité physique qu'il vente qu'il
pleuve ou qu'il neige au cours de ses
pérégrinations matinale michel se plaît
à rêver et à planifier sa journée dans
l'ensemble dans son quartier il estime
que les axes sont suffisamment bien
aménagé pour les piétons il n'a qu'un
seul reproche à faire quelquefois oui
effectivement je suis irrité parce que
comment dirais-je les passages protégés
en général sont pas forcément respectée
malheureusement et on se rend compte que
ya pas beaucoup de gens qui marchent
beaucoup de gens en voiture pour
quelques heures en vélo mais c'est
surtout notre voiture et a très peu de
gens qui marchent on a un peu le
sentiment que le piéton est pas
forcément toujours respecté et n'allez
pas lui parler d'écologie
à 66 ans michel n'a pas attendu la
révolution verte pour se mettre à
marcher
pour info selon le stif les franciliens
consacrerait 1h20 quotidiennement pour
se rendre au travail contre 17 minutes
en moyenne en province
d'après une étude publiée par
l'observatoire de la mobilité la marche
à pied arrive en tête des modes de
déplacements en ile-de-france tout type
de trajet confondues la voiture arrive
en second suivi des transports
collectifs